foreign
well good morning everybody and welcome
to development control B my name is
Kathy Guthrie and I'm the chairman today
may I read some domestic arrangements
please do not interrupt speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking if you're attending the meeting
to speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave please
ensure your mobile phones and laptops
are on silent
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern gov app so please
could members make sure they're logged
in and ready to use the app the council
members of the public and press May
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and press are
not lawfully excluded
so we have the introductions the area
planning manager Gemma Walker legal
advisor in Dupre police officers Alex
Scott and Nikita Mossman and she's being
helped by Avril next to her they look
like sisters don't they
um governance officer Alicia sat here
and we've got Beth who's steering our
internet which I'm sure will work very
nicely today won't even Beth
so on to the agenda apologies for
absence and substitutions do we have any
thank you chair we have apologies from
councilor Andrew Stringer we have
councilor Sarah Manson self-substituting
thank you
to receive any Declarations of
disclosable pecuniary interests or other
registerable interests or
non-registerable interests by members
are there any to declare
yes thank you chair yeah I should
declare that I was a member of The Stone
Market planning committee that discussed
item 7B on the agenda today okay thank
you
any site visits oh sorry
councilman yeah just uh declare that I'm
the county councilor for application 7A
thank you very much any further
visits
Declarations of site visits no
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 1st of March are
there any points regarding accuracy of
the minutes
no can I have a proposal please
councilor Muller and a second to do I
take that Council custom
and so we can now have an electronic
vote if we may please thank you
chair members that vote is now in
progress
thank you
thank you chair that is seven votes for
and one abstentions that is carried
thank you
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
none received here
okay um we'll do the planning
applications in the order in which they
appear and our bundle
so we start off with land east of
hunston Road badwell Ash and I'll know
about the case officer Alex Scott to
introduce the application please thank
you
well thank you chairman
um yes item 7A application reference
[Music]
dc2205701 this is an application for
approval of uh Reserve matters relating
to the layout scale appearance and
Landscaping in relation to 52 dwellings
which was granted act line planning
permission including access by committee
on the 24th of July 2019.
so this first slide is the location of
badwell Ash for the ordinance of doubt
and just for points of reference we have
bury some admins here
Stone Market just off the screen here
and I over here this over
the a14t
and the A14
this is a site location plan submitted
with the application
this is a wider aerial view of the site
um so to the as to the south of the
village
within a former sand and gravel Quarry
hunston Road
here and Wesley way to the uh to the
South
and here is a closer aerial
view of the site
and if we move to some constraints the
site presently sits outside of the
settlement boundary of the village which
is denoted by this brand
around here
there is a public right-of-way which
leads from the
the access to the sites
this boundary
to the bottom of the field and then
along
way to the uh to the South
the site does not lie within a special
landscape area however there is
the start of a special landscape area
across hunston road to the uh to the
North West
the site somewhat affects the setting of
a grade 2 listed building here to the
opposite side of hunston road
and these hatched areas represent
environment agency flood zones two and
three which again are to the South and
south west of the site and
site occupies Higher Ground within flood
zone one where there is the least
likelihood of flood flood risk
and there are also some
protected species issues most notably
toads on the site and all along uh
Hanston Road and Wesley way there are
warning notices of toads Crossing and
that has been a significant issue
with the application as explained within
the report
this is the layout
uh presently proposed so we have 34
Market dwellings and 18 affordable
dwellings
and there is a mix of uh one bedroom
apartments which
within the affordable dwellings in three
blocks
yeah
and the remainder would be a mix of two
three and four bedroom dwellings in a
mix of styles which I have slides
in a moment
um so the proposed housing mix the
orange and red represents a two-bedroom
dwellings
uh the green three-bedroom dwellings
and the blue four bedroom dwellings
and this is the proposed Landscaping
scheme so a variety new planting turfing
and some
more structural Landscaping to the
existing open boundary to the South and
eat along the uh the black right of way
here
now this feature here is the flood risk
attenuation Basin which would be
predominantly dry and unless
um instances of flooding and that has
been um
leveled and and graded in in accordance
with the recommendations of the um
the floods officer at the County Council
go around this is the proposed refuse
strategy showing a bin presentation and
storage points
and sweatpath Analysis has been
submitted and that has been
checked by your
waste strategy officer has raised no
objections
this is the proposed parking plan now
the the blue indicates parking for the
market dwellings there are 97 in total
the pink for the affordable dwellings
and there are 30 of those and the yellow
are for visitor parking and there are 13
of those and and
um
yes pleased to see no tandem parking has
been proposed
this is the materials plan so just
broadly there is a mix of um
of weathered and cream brick and facing
off-white uh roughcast render
and the roofs will be a mix of um
dark red and dark gray flats hand Tails
sorry plain tiles flat flat tiles
this is the proposed story Heights now
all the buildings would be two-story
um and the darker color you can see
there there's two buildings here they
would be the tallest at 9.3 meters and
then working down to um
5.2 meters with a medium height of 8.8
meters
these are the proposed Street Scenes now
this
uh yeah anyway sorry Technology's not
helping me at the moment but um yes if
you can see uh the the BB to the bottom
of the page the um that'd be what you
would see
um from hunston road but um it does have
an area of trees in front of it but um
cutting through that that would be um
the street scene there and
um the top at a a that would be looking
West uh down um
one of the uh one of the access roads to
the to the middle of the site that also
uh
shows slight levels I think uh very
accurately having been on site
now this is the um these are the
proposed front elevations of the market
dwellings
it's gonna have a mix of
um
three four and two bedroom there
although the two bedrooms
you could say that they're three
bedrooms because they have an upstairs
study that they are builders
two bedroom
and the other half of the market
dwellings there
and these are the affordable dwellings
so we have a
um
a number of these blocks to the uh
to the left of the screen there and they
would have
um
ground floor apartments and first floor
Apartments a mix of one and two bedroom
we would then have some two-bedroom
semi-detached and some three bedroom
semi-detached all in accordance with the
recommendation of your strategic housing
officer
and this slide just shows a comparison
between what was considered at outline
stage being indicative at that point so
that is on the left hand side of the
screen to the right side of the screen
is what is is currently proposed so
we're moving away from this um
this circular rope pattern to the center
um to a more um more linear Street Scene
pattern and
pulling dwellings around the existing
Lake to the middle of the site
and the attenuation Basin um
much smaller than originally built but
that is down to uh
down to requirements of the flood
Authority
so we're on to some photographs here
this is looking away from the site
down hunston Road and that shows the uh
the character of the existing
dwellings to the to the north
and then down the the opposite side
to the frontage of the site
and I'm sorry the pointer is not working
but you might be able to see just right
at the very far end where the road bends
round that is the point of access and
that access you can see in the in the
foreground is to the existing dwellings
and there is a small recycling center
there adjacent which people use and
people do um presently cut through here
to walk the site however that is not the
formal public right-of-way which would
be at the point of access which is
there and that cops of trees you can see
in the foreground that would all be
retained and enhanced there would be a
footpath through that connecting into
this it is doing a public footpath to
the Village Center and that includes a
sensory walking area which has been
discussed and proposed
now this is beyond that
um that cups of trees you saw there
across the site so this is the site's
present Northern boundary and that
little
cluster of vegetation to the right is
around the existing Lake to the center
of the site which is actually outside of
the red line site boundary but um we'll
see adjacent to it
and then moving around
looking South
along the existing trees all proposed to
be retained as part of the proposal and
enhanced
and finally we have a um the best view
from Westerly way most of Westerly way
is screened with vegetation but in this
Gateway you can see across the site and
the site is they're raised in the in the
in the background
if that gives a good idea of the
perception from that angle
um
so that really concludes the
presentation uh chair I set out in the
papers uh officer recommendation of
approval and there are a few items
um as part of the table papers
um one late response from public rights
of way
which removes its uh prior
concerns with regards to impact on the
public right-of-way the app they
consider the applicant has addressed
that with the latest layout you've seen
on screen there and also some
information
from the corporate manager building
control with regards ground stability
and Foundations which was raised by the
chair and vice chair at briefing so
hopefully that's helpful
so that concludes the presentation thank
you
thank you very much for that Alex and
also um thank you our briefing has gone
really well there because slide 20 I
think was very useful to show us the
comparisons it's all very well putting
one up but when you see the two side by
side it makes life a little easier to
just compare what was and what it what
is now suggested and uh thank you for
the late papers too
um an interesting question with an
interesting response actually because it
wasn't just totally no regarding the
fact that it had been a pit and it's now
been filled in albeit 30 years ago so
thank you for that that's very very
helpful
um any questions for the planning
officer
thank you uh thank you chair
um I've got a a couple of well three
queries actually
um in your presentation you talked about
two bed Market dwellings
um on page 28 of the papers uh section
2.4 it doesn't mention any two bed
Market dwellings so
um could you just clarify that shall I
do all the questions at once
um
so I mean uh technically the the floor
plans call
um
a few of the market dwellings two
bedroom but because of the presence of
an upstairs study it's technically could
be used for three bedroom dwellings
those so-called
two bed or three bed houses meet the
space standards
well that's the issue no they don't know
it would be a box office doesn't meet
the nationally described space standards
so um yes on the um on on the elevations
um I've tried to clarify that with the
uh the two-bedroom sort of but that's as
build from the from the applicant so so
in effect they they they're they're
being Builders to bed because they don't
meet the space standards for three
I think that's fair to say yes okay that
was my first question about the two bed
houses
um can you I mean on the plan it looks
quite a spacious development so could
you give us a identity housing density
that's the second question
studies are at the top of the report so
we have a um to have a gross density of
uh two point Sorry 20.8 dwellings per
hectare and a net net density
um subtracting the open space and the
sustainable drainage at uh 34.2
dwellings yes indeed it is in the report
you must have missed it and your third
question thank you my third question
um you had a photograph of the um Hanson
Road I think it was hunston Road
um I wear the existing uh pulling is
where the uh recycling bins are or
whatever they are now on the plan it
looks like there's a pavement a new
pavement going from that point to the
uh access to the development
um and it's quite wooded so are any
trees going to be removed to put that
Pavement in
this from the plant looks like there's a
pavement from that pull-in to the access
for the new development
I want to say there's a current
um
desire line path I think you could term
it that people do actually walk through
there that is supposed to be utilized so
there are no uh significant trees
proposed to be removed on the plan
there's a path through the trees which
is obviously the sort of Desire line one
but there also looks like there's a
pavement a new bit of pavement along the
side of the road on the plan
um
I'm just double checking I'm sure that
is the case but
yeah I've got the plan from the planning
portal up on my screen and it does say
new two meter wide footpath yes along
along hunston Road itself yes so that
would be the case so that's not going to
that's going to be without removing any
trees they can put that in without
doing anything other than trimming the
trees yes yes and there is uh from from
my perspective there is room within the
existing Verge that's my assistant
any further questions
of all boys and then councilman thank
you
um yeah would it be possible just to
expand a bit on the comments from
anglian water on page 21.
um
uh referring the
the carrot water recycling center which
I assume is a battle Ash Water of Life
recycling center
um being developed in order to cope with
the federal credit for misdevelopment
but the second paragraph it talks about
angry water review of the applicants
submitted foul drainage strategy
and consider the impact has not been
adequately addressed at this stage so
what sort of shade does that castle this
application in regards of
approving it
well I mean
at the time of writing that there wasn't
capacity now as I understand this isn't
a bit of a bit of flux you know it
really depends at what points you you
consult them now the applicant
separately has consulted anglian water
another point that they consulted them
they said there was capacity so um it is
a little bit of flux over time as I
understand but um
I mean the Water Authority are obliged
to accept the development and to um to
mitigate that
um yeah as part of their obligations so
it would be something that uh they and
the applicant would need to uh
need to sort out now in order to can I
just interject them and just ask you a
good self if I may on on your behalf you
might be thinking it as well is um if um
can we put a clause in or something that
Anglia before things start that Anglia
water have to accept that they must be
able to mitigate the issue that
councilor War boys is Raising
Japan
if you don't mind so essentially anglian
water have an obligation to take the
flows regardless and what we tend to
find happens is it's a matter of phasing
of the infrastructure so there is a
combination of which the way this comes
forward and to where the angling water
infrastructure comes forward so it might
be more of a phasing requirement so that
we understand this will come forward at
this only house here and we know that
the angling water infrastructure comes
forward together in that way rather than
a other restriction yeah
um and so if you'd like to continue
thank you and we've got a bit of a
response we can use it in debate thank
you and second part of my question was
about the um applicants submitted found
drainage strategy that Anglia water
uh don't feel has been adequately
addressed
so they're putting the onus there I
think on the applicant to produce a foul
drainage strategy
yeah that's down to the uh the applicant
and anglian water to um
yeah to remedial amongst themselves I
would uh I would imagine but uh yeah
I'll just reiterate they are obliged to
accept the flows
uh yeah and and this needs to be sorted
out
um
I mean I'm not sure what uh relevance
this really has to the reserve matters I
mean
yeah absolutely so we've got a couple
things that this would have been part of
the in principle discussions on the
outline so we do have to bear that in
mind along the way and also I think what
that is driving at is that we haven't
got requested for the flows hence the
concern over the foul drainage but once
the capacity becomes sorted through
anger water infrastructure that should
knit together but again I think we could
perhaps weave something by worth
condition and perhaps Alex and I'll just
have a quick look at the outline
um and check if there's anything further
that might help us there yeah I just
wonder if we can put a condition on to
say that no occupation until that's
sorted I mean you know if they want to
build it and take the chance
no but we'll discuss that again but a
very valid point any further input on
that one Council of War boys
no we can always ask the agent for that
thank you very much Council Merlin
yes thank you chair
um just um want to ask a question about
toads
um the local toe group put in a report
which had four recommendations in it
um
sorry I'm getting things from behind you
carry on Council
um
so I can only see that one of those
recommendations has been taken up which
is the drop curbs which is good to see
but there was three others amphibian
ladders in the open drains and gullies
and amphibian tunnel under the road and
amphibian fencing but I couldn't see
those in the um ecology sort of
recommendations
perhaps if they're not we can add them
in our discussion and add it to it but
rather than sort of worry about
um whether it's specifically the last
two bits we can make sure that's
included would you be happy with that
counselor
councilman has another question yes
please uh hopefully this is a quick one
um can you just confirm that the
footpath that's on the sort of western
side the current existing public right
of way
is going to be open you know there's no
fence between the open space on the plan
and that footpath
and so on the Landscaping plan that is
uh going to have a a two meter wide uh
buffer by the looks of things and
um yeah that has been checked by public
rights of way who are happy with the
latest uh layout that's been so you can
go from the from the public open space
of the new development straight onto the
footpath No No fences
no fences no no
thank you very much
um could you show me the path of the
electric wires that came up on the um
on the map please
I believe they come down that left hand
side as we see it but I just want to
know exactly where they are
yeah and there's another um yeah this is
the other one you can see the power line
in the longer Street Scene really yeah
yeah it would be over the proposed
footpath but um
do they follow the road beside it or do
they actually go over the site please
it's very hard to tell from yeah of
course yeah Okay Google Earth doesn't
always show you um
um so to the north of the site there you
can see there another
um Telegraph poll there
but um yeah from my site visit
it's not something I considered
specifically but yeah
yeah from memory there was nothing
um crossing the site um but there is
something to the uh to the north and to
the north um Northwest along Hanston
road yeah
right okay thank you
thank you very much indeed
um
we do we have anyone from the parish
council no an objector no supporter
[Music]
agent
So Jamie Martin Edwards James Bailey
Ellie George waska and Wayne warsdal
assist with answering questions but you
only have three minutes so please give
us your three minutes that will be very
very helpful thank you
thank you chair and good morning
my name is Jamie Martin Edwards I'm a
senior planner for James baby planning
and I'm joined today by James Bailey
along with Wayne worsdale of mobile
we have been leading on this application
for Reserve matters at land east of
huntsman Road badwell Ash between us we
should be able to answer any questions
you may have
the site already benefits from an
outline planning permission which was
secured in January 2020 therefore the
principle of residential development has
been accepted and the application day
before you includes appearance layout at
scale and Landscaping
this is Moby homes first project in
mid-suffolk and as such they're invested
in creating an Exemplar scheme of low
density housing that is worthy of its
setting and will capture the essential
character of the existing built
environment of badwell Ash mobile homes
have continued to collaborate with
badwell Ash Parish Council ensuring that
the parish have had a positive influence
on the proposed development this
includes a bespoke sensory play area and
Woodland walk to complement the other
recreational facilities within the
village badwell Ash Parish Council have
offered their support on the application
during the consultation period
Moby homes have also engaged in two
pre-apps to ensure that this site
delivers on several considerations
including drainage highways and ecology
members will note in the papers that
there are no holding objections from
these statutory consultees the proposal
delivers 52 dwellings including 18
affordable houses and the housing mix
has been established and agreed by the
council strategic housing officer and
the section 106.
all dwellings will have an electric
vehicle charging Point water butts to
store rain water and will be heated by
air source heat pumps the application
includes an ecology enhancement strategy
which sets out a suite of enhancements
and mitigation measures this includes
information boards that will be
strategically located within the site to
educate future residents and visitors
about the fauna and floor of the site a
curb free area at the main axis to
support migration of toads the strategy
also includes an amphibian hibernacular
enhancements to the existing Woodlands
as well as Hedgehog fencing
public open spaces have been provided in
two locations the first at the front of
the site ensures the development is set
back from the access and creates a
buffer to the northern woodland area a
path through this Woodland will offer a
direct link to the existing pedestrian
Network into badwell Ash this is in
addition to the more formalized engineer
footpath linking the main access from
hunson Road into badwell Ash the second
open space is located around the suds
area and creates an important feature
and buffer to the boundaries shared with
the fishing lake adjacent to the site to
conclude the reserve matters application
for this site benefits from an existing
outline consent Mulberry is committed to
a well-designed scheme for the site that
incorporates a number of sustainable
measures including ecology enhancements
electric charging points and 100
airsource heat pumps the scheme before
you today has been developed for
extensive discussions with your offices
Suffolk County Council anglian water and
badwell Ash Parish Council there are no
objections from any statutory or
consultants and has been praised from
the parish council for the scheme I
therefore respectfully request members
to endorse their officer's
recommendation and approve the
application today thank you very much
for your time and hope we can answer any
of your questions
thank you very much indeed I forgot to
put my three minutes on but I think you
made it well within the time
you're the first victim I'm going to ask
and probably the last I'll ever ask have
you ever heard of the Lucy group
apologies
no secret limited because they have a
wonderful development of using Street
lamps to put electric charging points in
have you ever heard of them personally I
have not known no right I'll bring this
into the debate but that was my question
to you and I think as developers you'd
be well advised to research thank you
anyway questions to the planners
councilor Mallon
thank you chair um
good to see you again Mr Martin Edwards
um
can I ask a question about PV panels you
didn't talk about putting any on the
ruse what's the orientation of the roofs
and and have you considered adding those
on as a sort of an extra
economic Peak ecological benefit
thank you councilman a great question we
as part of condition 14 of the outline
application is a requirement to submit
sustainability appraisal setting out the
Energy Efficiency of the site that
condition was discharged in January of
this year the wording within that
condition required to ensure that there
was an intent to go above and beyond 30
over building regs in this instance the
report that was submitted along with the
application and the condition that was
discharged back in January
um through the methods that we're using
of 100 seat pump the water
retention the use of sanitary wear
within the development itself we're
actually over 57
so it was considered at the time we've
gone well beyond and there was no
necessary need based on that condition
that's been discharged to go any further
I think that answers the question I
don't want debate on it but it's just
answers the question if there's a
further question please do
can I can I ask a question about the
Toads is that possible
I asked the officer about the tow
measures earlier I wonder if have you
considered
um and it's good to see the drop curbs
or the area without curbs have you
considered um putting an amphibian
tunnel under the access road
yes uh the answer to that question is
yes we've been in liaising with the tele
Patrol since before Christmas we met
them out on site um we've had extensive
conversations with the parish councils
as well on this matter
um initial questions coming back from
Suffolk County Council was would this
affect any adoptable status this
includes the drainage ladders as well
because they are in essence
um freestanding infrastructure that goes
into the drain so if they were to come
loose and fall off within the drain what
impact does that have
um it then questioned the adoptability
and that's why we then looked at other
deliverable options available and that's
why we actually submitted the
enhancement strategy that wasn't a
requirement of the reserve matters in
that instance we've had conversations
with our Consultants from an oncology
perspective and we look to see what we
could do from an educational perspective
so that's why we've got additional
information boards we're looking to
support the tote Patrol in the future as
well as part of this application and as
you said we we looked to deliver on the
drop curbs because that's something we
can clearly do interest need the two
Woodland areas that have been identified
on the site is in essence where the
hibernation
the Toads takes place and the ponds that
they migrate to in breeding seasons is
on the other side of hunston road so in
essence the Toads movements through our
liaising with the tow Patrol who are
experts in the area and yearly annually
go out and help the Toads cross the road
is not necessarily totes crossing the
grassland that you saw on those pictures
there it's from The Woodlands into the
next woodlands and then across the road
so the idea with the proposals that
we've put forward today is to ensure
that we're enhancing that migration path
by keeping both Woodlands you'll note in
the outline permission it was to strip
one of those Woodlands out completely
and put it an open space in there on
those two plans so what we've tried to
look to do is maximize the opportunity
with the existing habitats within them
and that's why we've not necessarily
done the tunnels for example the other
part of the tunnels in hunston Road
themselves would enter into third-party
land so there's no guarantee that they
could be delivered it will also require
ripping up hunston road to put in that
infrastructure as well which is
obviously quite costly as we've seen
from the Consulting comments there's no
requirement from your colleges to do
that hopefully that was um a long answer
that does give us a long thing I don't
think we need any more on that one I
think we've done to
frog spawn and Beyond on that one thank
you
Council wall voice and then councilor
Mansell thank you
yes
um you could probably guess what the
question is going to be about Anglia
water of queered your
foul drainage strategy could you tell us
where you are with regard to addressing
those concerns
thank you Council always
um so the initial comments that came in
from anger and water were right in terms
of questioning because at the time we
hadn't included with our drainage
strategy
um the the sewage water strategy because
there wasn't a requirement at that stage
however as a result of those Consulting
comments we opened up the pre-app which
has been submitted on the application
and is on the planning portal that was
submitted in January this year and in
essence we went and had conversations
about high level engineering to ensure
that we can meet the the demands that
are needed from England water the
pre-app response that's on the on the
website came back and said yes we do
have capacity based on what it is that
you're proposing as along with as I
mentioned earlier the Energy Efficiency
with the sanitary wear to reduce the
amount of water used per household And
in regards to that we submitted this
pre-app response from them to to provide
reassurances to the council officers and
to members and a subsequent pre-app
sorry subsequent consultation to anglian
water on their own pre-app took place
the last comments back from
with no objection on this basis
and I just interrupt though please it's
the planners who deal with that did you
have that response yourselves
that there was no
exactly yeah it's up to the planners to
make sure between the Anglia water
despite your enthusiasm I would have
thought we shall we debate that point
councilman it's not in the documents is
it or if I missed it
is
I'm just looking on page 21 of the
papers we've got Angeline Waters
comments on the 25th of November which
do include the comment about the foul
drainage strategy but the comments below
then are the 27th of March this year
which confirms they have had a further
review I think
um they know they're unable to write
comments on the surface water management
but we've got that separately from
Suffolk County floods
um
and I think that addresses the key Point
obviously there's still the phasing of
the infrastructure scenario and as I
said as we debate maybe we can put
something in place councilman's shaking
his head but for debate let's put that
in for the debate rather than now do you
have a further question it's
um so we're getting a rather long-winded
replies we're getting a rather a debate
rather than answer to the
um
the uh some of the um
uh joins uh show chimneys on several of
the houses so those purely decorative
yeah that's correct that's not on all
houses as a result of our consultation
uh prior to Christmas with the parish
council and we had recognized that there
is a character within the area around
Chimneys in the street scene we had put
forward that option to the Parish
Council on the development to have faux
chimneys to complement that character as
I said it's not on all of them and that
was something that they've set out in
their comments that they would like to
see to ensure from from their
perspective uh albeit subjective that
the character of the area was cohesive
so we've put them on some of them to
kind of that tie in with your existing
character of badwell Ash but yes that's
correct they are all faux chimneys
there's no fireplaces being proposed in
this instance
okay thank you
an answer thank you I've got a couple of
questions uh the first one in relation
to the parish council's comments as well
as the faux chimney pots they've also
asked that the road through the
development is going to be adopted
um can you I know you can't tell me if
Suffolk County Council going to adopt it
but is it to adoptable standard
yes second question follows on from
councilor mellon's comments about PV
panels
um can you are you able to assure us
that any future resident at in this
development will be able to put solar
panels on the roofs without restriction
as I've heard that that is a restriction
on some of other new developments in the
district thank you
that's more for the planning officer
isn't it to put restrictions on is it
not the developer puts restricted
governance on development to not allow
solar panels on the front aspect and I
just wanted to check that that wasn't
going to be the case here yet my
colleague Wayne here is confirmed that
Mulberry homes would have no objection
of ensuring no confidence in regards to
installing solar panels for future
thank you and
could you help me out with this um root
of the power lines on the site please
thank you
would it be helpful if we could put
slide 20 up which show would show you
the layout plan
that photo there you just saw the
telegraph poll is situated if we look at
the right hand side layout plan we've
got the northern parcel of green
Woodland area
recycling bins are that is located there
now those power lines wrap around
outside of the red line plan around the
top of that northern woodland area and
it's actually indicated where those
annotation there's like a paragraph
annotations there that's exactly it
there's some lines indicated on that
plan outside of the red line that shows
where those lines are
hopefully that sounds so just to confirm
they're outside the red line plan that's
correct yeah in the northern part the
closest that they're just to the north
of no sorry apologies of the actual site
overall site as well yep so okay thank
you very much thank you
thank you no you're probably um
complained to me but just listening to
the questions obviously can
I might have missed it with the ecology
on the tones
are there likely to be any signage or
anything to assist people with their
education on it and things like that I
mean I don't know I might have missed it
I apologize yes or no is the answer yes
and we're also looking at giving the
occupiers when they come into the new
homes uh information about the toads in
the local area as well so that has been
agreed with Mulberry that will be
provided to the new occupiers can I
recommend that you put on them that
toads are poisonous to dogs
noted thank you
right
fourth award member to give us views
please councilor mayor would you like to
tell us your views yeah thanks chair
um
the parish council and people of
bandwalash fully accept the principal
development principle of development has
been
um
established and these houses will be
built
um just for reference this was a
controversial development within the
village and resulted in
um solicitors being engaged by different
members of The Village to fight their
particular Corners so we are talking
about a very sensitive issue
um
I'd also like to point out that babalash
of a village of 280 houses has had
getting on for 200 additional dwellings
being built or being built in the area
so huge amount of development for quite
a small village and I'll return to that
because of that there are very real
concerns about infrastructure in the
village
very real concerns
Mulberry homes have to be complemented
they came into this
development and have worked hard to
establish a strong viable working
relationship with the Paris Council and
in that they've been very successful and
I think the results of that can be seen
in what is I think quite from my
perspective a good quality development
it's very pleasing to see air source
heat pumps and future residents will not
be looking at large retrofit costs
e-charging all properties
excellence and the support from Mulberry
homes for the toads
which seem to be a very prominent part
of badwell Ash culture and if you've
ever seen the hordes of people out on a
wet rainy night trying to save them as
they cross the road you'll know how
passionate they are about their totes so
I'd like to thank on behalf of the
Parish Council on worldly homes for
their efforts
District councilor you always want a bit
more and it
it's nice to see the financial support
for the Toads that has gone in place the
tunnel was always going to be a a big
ask because Mulberry homes don't own all
the land so it as well has been
expensive it was going to be difficult
but options for solar panels don't cost
very much and it would be nice to see
that offered to Residents as a an option
and one would hope that the
um the electrical infrastructure in each
of the homes will be constructed in such
a way that retrofitting panels will be
relatively simple
so is everything Rosy in the garden
sadly not
anger water have stated that the water
recycling center cannot take the
drainage
that's all right because it's their
problem not ours
well sadly I'll put in front of you we
the planning committees have created
this problem
200 additional dwellings in a village of
280 houses is always going to put
massive pressure on the infrastructure
so to turn around and say it's not our
problem angular water's got to sort it
out I don't think it's actually a
position that the residents of badwal
Ash would find very easy to accept
I was very pleased to hear the chair
start talking about conditions because
that that is the solution that I would
like to put before you
Anglia water have invested
in the treatment plant
there's a new storm tank so that the
emergency release is when it's been
raining should stop
in 2001 68 times raw sewage left that
treatment plant and went into the water
courses around badwalesh
now
what's raw sewage going to do to the
toads and all the other floor and fauna
in the area
will Anglia water accept their
responsibilities
yes probably in the long term
how many more emergency releases are
going to take place in the interim
I would like to put pressure on anger
water and I would like to suggest or ask
you to consider a condition that no
houses are occupied until such time as
Anglo water have confirmed that they
have capacity
what will this do
this
will give Mulberry homes Leverage
if they've built out their site and
Anglia water has not lived up to their
um
responsibilities then I'd suggest they
would be very easily action taken
against angler water which will
encourage Anglia water to get on with it
and if anger water do come forward and
confirm that there is capacity
then when they pull the emergency lever
and release raw sewage it will give the
residents of bad well Ash
greater leverage to take action against
Anglia water
nobody wants to see raw sewage in the in
the water courses around their Village
and banglash is no different
we the planning committees have nearly
doubled that Village
that Village that has no school
one small shop
is now nearly 200 extra homes
that's a huge weight of responsibility
and I think I'd ask the planning
committees to assist battle Ash in in
their drive to get Anglia water to live
up to their responsibilities
thank you
thank you very much for that very
passionate and and absolutely
on the mark
report to us and one of the things I've
done over the years my training told me
that I never discuss any application as
a planning committee member with any
other member on that committee
but that doesn't always happen but I can
assure you I have not discussed with
councilor mayor the issue of putting a
condition on of no occupation before
um occupy you know no occupation before
Anglia water accepts their
responsibilities and I can absolutely
uphold that that's what I will be
looking for as a condition as the debate
goes forward so thank you councilor
mayor at least we've been thinking along
the same lines be it telepathy we've
never discussed it so thank you for that
any questions for the ward member
Council of War boys
um just just a question about a date
really you mentioned
2001 and since then Anglia water have
improved the site
did I say 2001 it was 2021 sorry
um simply because I looked up some
information on the river trusts and in
stonewater overflow spilled 32 times for
a total of 443.5 hours into salary Brook
so whatever Anglia water have done
hasn't really solved this problem
I was talking to an angler water
executive um just two days ago and he
informed me about the storm water tank
that's been implemented I am not sure
when that came on on Stream So when
their enhancements actually became
operational I don't know
so that's something that needs to be
clarified perhaps yeah
thank you
questions
any other questions for the ward member
thank you very much indeed right well I
think we've got a lot of interesting
questions and answers and what uh just
looked like one application has got some
rather intriguing twists and turns who'd
like to start me off councilor Muller
please
yes thank you chair thank you very much
for everyone for their comments and
questions Etc I too like yourself chair
and some of the members here today are
really concerned about this Angie and
water issue and it was very well put
forward by cage the mayor and I
definitely think we should consider a
condition
of adding to this application if we
choose to pass it that condition should
be added that perhaps no building should
be occupied until anger and wardrobe
solved the problem but
thank you councilor Gould
thank you thank you chair and like
Pastor well I'm I'm grateful to uh
colleagues on the committee for the
questions uh that they put but
particularly councilor wall boys who
avoided the need for me to ask the
question that he so eloquently uh asks
uh my concerns with this uh otherwise
excellent application are about the
situation with the danglion water and
um I I too would support the
um the writing in of a condition as as
has been described
and I'd compliment Council mayor on his
his
um his Personnel I thought he presented
the points extremely well and sometimes
it's good to step back from the
application and see the impact of what
we are agreeing we look at individual
locations but sometimes stepping back
and looking at the impact the the
cumulative impact of that is important
to do that and it's all very well to say
that Anglia water have obligations which
they must meet but as a public body
really we ought to be making sure that
we're approaching things in a Collegiate
and constructive
attractive manner because it's no
consolation to anyone if we see the the
problems in the future including
discharges as has been described so
um I would though complement the the
applicant I think this is a very good
application indeed and not least in
terms of the
um their engagement with with body's
concern particularly the parish council
it seems such an obvious uh and positive
way to proceed and it constantly
surprises me that it's sent to which
other developers don't do this so I know
this is your first uh first development
in mid-suffolk but I commend the
approach that you've taken and hope that
you carry on taking taking that approach
a brief mention before I set out to the
question of faux chimneys which have
come that from time to time in this
committee and I think there's kind of a
view being expressed that
these are probably add to the building
costs and represent a future liability
and so the the balance of benefit of cop
that cost uh liability isn't really an
attractive one so and I've noticed that
you've only put it on a proposal on a
few houses so uh perhaps we can have a
rethink about that on the other hand the
parish council it's something that is
important to them so it's a minor Point
bit
um I would certainly be supportive of
this of this application with the
condition that's been proposed here
thank you
thank you very much
forgot who was next I think it was to
the Mansell and then councilor custon
thank you thank you um I I too would
like to commend the developer for for
his engagement with the parish council I
think there's a lot of uh quite a lot of
thought and and good design has gone
into this proposal I too have a couple
of niggles one of them is faux chimneys
I don't like uh things that are
pertaining to be things that they're not
uh but um I guess we just need to
educate badwell Ash Parish Council of
the Folly of their ways for a future
development
um and I think looking at the plan there
do seem to be not a high proportion of
uh houses with roofs oriented uh for uh
best solar gain but you do seem to have
done a lot of other energy saving
um environmentally friendly initiatives
with this development
and thank you very much for making sure
that any future resident will be able to
put solar panels on
um because I I've only recently
discovered that these things have been
restricted
um so that that's good
um I I too am concerned about water
drainage
um and it's obviously become quite a big
thing at the moment
um but I have I have a little bit of a
doubt in my mind about imposing a
condition on another body if we impose a
condition for anglian water to sort out
what they're doing with the surface
water drainage or whatever it is
um that is outside of the developers
control
um and I know of other
developments within my ward where
conditions have been put on outside
bodies and they're just not done so I
would like some
um confirmation from the legal and the
planning officers that it is possible to
put a condition on Angry mortar before I
um before I can make a proposal
yeah um I think um the chief planning
officer wants to have a word a five
minute timeout at what point do you want
to do that do you want to stop the
debate now before we go any further um I
think we're all on the same page
um and then we can come back to debate
once you've had some discussion would
that be helpful now
um perhaps if I just set out some of the
issues see where we get to and then if
we need to we can take the five minutes
if members are satisfied because I'm
hearing a strong practice all that
conditions I mean you know so councilor
Mansell makes a very valid point however
we have put in place which restrictions
on occupation until on other things and
I know you've said that they haven't
they haven't always worked and you can't
blame the developer because the
developers okay okay I hear what you're
saying but I'm just saying we need to
sort of be clear on what we can do to
assist
yeah because the end of the day we need
to get the right outcome
so um let's continue with with our did
you want to would you mind yes no please
join in that will help us through my
debate so we've got a couple of issues
that I've been looking into with sort of
perhaps wear angling water may or may
not have changed directional or done
various things from what I can see on
the outline they raise no objection
that's that's the only comment I've got
I cannot find their full comments so I
don't know more than that that's
literally what was reported back to
community was no objection on the
outline that then feeds into this in
that we are looking at Reserve matters
so scale appearance layout and
Landscaping
so that comes a question where we may
draw in in on the possibility of doing
that that really this is an outline one
question and can we do anything that
Reserve matters so we might need to take
that away and have that conversation and
again depending on some advice from Ian
what we have done in the past again on
an outline rather than Reserve matters
is
looking to agree a phasing plan with a
developer so that the phasing of the
development would come in line with the
angling water development so it doesn't
require that angling water does
something what it does is restrict the
development coming forward or being
occupied until the matching
infrastructure is delivered by angling
water and essentially that's kind of a
forward planning for the delivery of the
infrastructure but I said that's on
outline and that's the kind of naughty
question that we've just been trying to
dig through a little bit more on for you
um while that's been in a debate so I
don't know
I be heard um
excuse me a moment
[Music]
um yes indeed I agree um councilor
Mansell if I may say so um did part of
my job for me she's absolutely right but
it well you can have this this wouldn't
be a grampian condition it
you you can sometimes say that something
won't happen until something else does
happen but it's it is only to be done if
it's necessary and proportionate and
unavoidable
and there is an issue that this is this
is not we're not an outline stage or
full commission we're dealing with
Reserve matters that doesn't mean we
can't do anything but yes I just say I
agree with Mrs Walker and I think we
we do need a bit of a little time to
discuss this further perhaps with
yourself Madam chair and the uh and
or do you want to take that now or
before the debate I mean you know
because obviously I think everybody is
sort of thinking um
just a minute councilor melon I'll come
to you in a minute
um I don't want to stop at a good debate
but on the other hand if we have some
more information it might change the
angle of the debate a bit what do you
think um I'll ask in really as to do we
have five minutes now or
what do you think
um
we'll continue
yes but you can hear the the views of of
the people so uh councilman had you
finished I think and then councilor
customers next and then cancel the melon
if you would please thank you
yeah so um more of the same I think it's
um it's so important that um these um
committees
know that there's adequate
infrastructure especially sewage
um I would like to see Anglia water
um give us a full capacity assessment of
what's going on there but I do
completely understand as well
if they don't want to do it the
developers are being penalized but at
the same time
I don't want to that to be the process
that things work under because that
process is completely wrong because
we're forever building things that we
haven't got capacity for and you know
that's not the way it's supposed to work
um
I won't talk too much on that because
we're obviously going to take the five
minutes and talk about what we can do
and um I'll see how I feel about the
conclusion that comes to
um fake chimneys
um wouldn't it wouldn't it be um great
if those fake chimneys had a purpose in
a form of biodiversity or bees birds or
bats that made them not chimneys at all
but something in the shape of a chimney
that served a purpose on top of the
house to um to provide harborage for
some for whatever it's necessary for
um I wouldn't have a problem at all with
a fake chimney on our house if it was
doing something other than looking like
a chimney so um
there's the big thing on this that's
keeping me
um from making a decision is this need
for capacity in the sewage system I'll
wait and see how that turns out from the
discussions that are going on but um
thank you I have no position on this at
the moment thank you
it's very interesting
and the Burglar Alarm they couldn't test
it because the bats were in the burglar
alarm so they had to disconnect it and
I've got another one on there this year
when they come again I expect they're
going to be in there so um it's a very
interesting concept that thank you for
that
um so we move on to councilor melon if
you would please
yeah thank you chair no
strike a Brilliance Council casting
for business marketing those do very
well um yeah for bees and so forth um so
a couple of things before I turn to the
um the angling water thing so on the
toad tunnel um just to give a little bit
of good news
um in my role as County councilor I had
discussions with highways officers and
there is a double Culvert underneath
hunston Road
and they think that one of those could
be um amended to become a tow tunnel
under there so that's that's a really
good can I just interrupt you there who
owns the land on that well it's the
highways yeah right okay yeah thank you
um
so um I mean I I would obviously prefer
to see PV panels even if you've got
um air source heat pumps they do need
electricity to run them and although it
tends to be you need the heat pump when
when the sun isn't shining
um PV panels and batteries would be a
good result for those homeowners um and
they can be quite expensive to run the
the air source heat pumps but I'll leave
that to one side so just to turn to the
main issue which I think is the angling
water
seeing
um members will remember we debated in
this chamber back in November last year
about
the issue of
of sewage outflows into streams and we
again unanimously agreed
emotion then
be pleased to see in this report a
section talking about the the impact of
of that on on water courses I think it's
the first one I've seen actually in a in
a report so it's great to see that
um but it was made very clear during
that debate that we couldn't use the
issue of
potential
spillages of sewage in towards courses
to refuse an application we just don't
have the policy
for that to stand on so I I really like
the idea that we can impose a condition
if that's possible
um
we don't have any
on our own
policy that would prevent or that would
allow us to refuse an application on
those grounds the only thing we do have
is is the mppf and there's one paragraph
174e which talks about preventing new
development from contributing to
water pollution
so I just want to add that into the the
debate and maybe into the into the
timeout discussion
um
just to go back on um the figures that
that Council War boys mentioned 2021
um this is the one that councilor mayor
quoted there were 68 flood events where
the combined storm overflow
is charged into the water course over a
thousand hours last year it was less
than half that 32 and 443 and a half
hours but if you remember last year was
a very very dry year so there wasn't
those kind of high rainfall events
which would generate the flows that
would just spill over so I'm not
entirely sure where you know how much
the the facilities and the
infrastructure has been enhanced at the
the babelash
treatment works and I would clearly like
to see that enhanced if that can
possibly be achieved thank you chair
planning committee
committee could I pop in here thank you
so
um
I'll come back to this application a
second absolutely on an outline yes I
think we're absolutely in a position as
I said we've got a condition that's
actually audified but I have some good
news so yes in the future is my definite
position on that if we've got an outline
or a full we can definitely do something
by conditions so that we've got that
certainty that as the houses come out of
the water we know terrible pun sorry as
they come out of the water that the
infrastructure for the drainage will
come at the same time however I've been
having another detailed read on the
pre-planning from anglian water on the
13th of January and if I read it the
foul drainage from the proposed
development is in the catchment of bad
oil Ash water recycling center which
currently has capacity to treat the
flows from your development site anglian
water cannot Reserve capacity and the
available capacity of the water
recycling can be reduced at any time due
to growth environmental and regulation
driven changes so that is the beginning
of this year that says they did have
capacity so I suspect is why we had
their amended
comments but that seems to me that they
do have the capacity and I suppose it's
a which house gets built out to fill the
capacity will be something that
ultimately angling water do need to deal
with and I hope give members more
certainty over this current scenario but
again makes me
less happy to put a condition on that
they do seem to be working on this so in
other words at the next stage because
people don't understand that you get
outline and then you get reserved
matters and then you get the full
application
um so what you're saying is a lot of
what we're worried about could be
um helped at a full application
and more teeth given to it I think if if
that's the explanation I can give but I
mean should members be minded to approve
could we put an informative on that at
the outline that these aspects need to
be addressed does that give almost a
grampian condition on the next bit if
you like
so I think from my side I was going back
in the processes if we were talking at
an outline today absolutely yes I'll be
there ultimately we have done that we
had no objection from them then
they currently said as a January this
year that they had capacity
and probably in this case I think
bearing my Reserve matters we probably
need to follow that
and leave that with angling water but
yes in the future on other cases I
suppose I was saying the okay so I'm
talking about this if you wanted an
informative that might be the way to go
for the the developer who actually
hearing them listening to review that
capacity with angling water but I've got
to give Comfort to everybody myself as
well that we know that that
we don't want to or legally we can't
block the application which we wouldn't
want to because we're all very happy
with all the hard work that's going on
on it but equally we don't want to be
the people that say well sorry bad well
actually you're going to get them so I
mean I'm
reluctious of that do you still want
five minutes out
um to to then come back and give Comfort
to the committee because I can see the
looks on everybody's faces is we're not
confident that this is going to yeah do
that back stock given the strength of
feeling I think that might be worth us
just just seeing what other options five
minutes if you would please could
um and we
about in in the corridor there is that
all right and you know
because as you all are
so could you just
well thank you very much for the short
interlude there um very interesting
conversations but I think um you know
when you realize what um Ian's going to
tell us I think you'll sort of see where
we're probably going on this one I mean
a lot of people don't understand you
have outline you have reserved matters
and then you have a full application and
that's where the problem sits so in if
you would like to just explain a little
further as to what might give Comfort to
the committee members yes if I may I say
first of all it's not my job to tell the
committee what to do but to give legal
advice
um now what a
uh in in this room in in public session
when we're on YouTube what we said to
you madam chairman outside that
in this matter the an outline permission
for 52 dwellings has been granted that
that is that's a given and it's it's
um capable of being
implemented as soon as Reserve matters
approval is is given
gets charged
so we we have the principle of 52
dwellings
this Reserve matters application is
about it's not about access because that
is a reserved matter but was dealt with
the outline as it commonly is on any
estate development we're left with a
scale appearance and layout so we we
have can totally understandable concerns
from all well I think every member of
the committee who's spoken on the ward
member about the what I'll call the
anglian water situation the the sewage
management
um
go through those three things appearance
scale and layout the appearance of
dwellings has no impact that I can think
of on on that this scale might to a
degree because of the the size of
dwellings and the occupation and so
forth might have relate to the the
sewage issue and are in some situations
the layout of an estate might but I'm
not I'm not sure if it is so I'm
applying those factors that there is
some room for maneuver for the committee
I'm but I'm afraid I'm not sure that in
this case with this 52 dwellings the um
scale or the layout gives you very much
of a legal basis for a commit for a
condition at this stage at outline it
would have been legally possible given
the right set of circumstances and
advice
there is room of course for an
informative which my office my planner
colleagues will advise you further on
but that that is my I'm afraid that is
my reluctant legal advice to you at this
moment
thank you Ian and just one moment cancer
melon if we can just sort of finish this
off
um Gemma I think we sort of had a
discussion would you like to share that
regarding an informative that we could
put on this
you thank you chair
um so I think working through some
possible wording and bear in mind we've
got the applicant nation in the room
obviously have heard that and
absolutely aware of that as an issue
because they will need to deliver it
alongside Anglican water that we can put
that on as an additional informative to
um note that this needs addressing they
need to be in contact with ankling water
to secure the delivery of the angling
water infrastructure alongside the
phasing of the development
and also what we've got to remember
members as we're discussing
seem to be any room here for a refusal
because we haven't got grounds for a
refusal at this stage so um cancer melon
if if you want to sort of enter into the
debate please do you had your hand up
um
your turn and then I will say something
after well just to make a cup
of culture um the first one is
clearly since the uh the outline was
approved as councilor mayor told us
there have been a number of other
applications and developments within
baboulash so there's a material change
when the outline was approved which
apparently had no objections from
anglian water and today
there's a very different situation so
that's the first coin the second point
is that in the mppf paragraph 174e which
I quoted it doesn't say anything about
outline or Reserve matters it just says
preventing new development from
contributing to water pollution and
taking out some of the irrelevant words
there so I don't know that if we could
rest some of the concerns on on this
paragraph
that doesn't seem to me to
to apply only to outline permissions
yeah but you've got legal advice that
we've just taken on the legal advice
um
preventing new and existing development
from contributing to being put at an
acceptable risk from or being adversely
affected by unacceptable levels of soil
air water or noise pollution or in land
instability development should wherever
possible help to improve local
environmental conditions such as air and
water quality taking into account
relevant information such as River Basin
management plans
so that that is paragraph 174 as a whole
so it starts by saying planning policies
and decisions so the council when it's
making a new plan
a um
village with its neighborhood plan
should and and also decisions are you
then that you're quite right councilman
that doesn't include today making a
decision
should do all these things and E is
preventing new and existing that is
absolutely right but all I would say is
it means as far as you're legally
capable of doing so on the day given
what's already happened and what is
already
the applicants control and you know if
you're going to do this on this one
you're going to do it on all
applications that come before you that
they say you know I mean it
it's outside their control they know
that they've got an application that
could go forward and because Anglia
water are dithering
the next stage you could then put in
put in about no occupation couldn't you
um Gemma
um
so
we have another stage on this one
um but they've got they've got to do
this Reserve matters so we would we
potentially have any conditions that
we're still need dealing with but then
we'd have to have valid that by now what
I would say is angling water should have
been aware of each of those applications
as they come take on wood and top and
Todd them up cumulatively so
day one we get 52 in and we say we've
got enough we know then we've got
another however many added on top of
that they should be aware and obviously
we did have that consultation
responsible this pre-planning report
that's that we've got saying that there
was capacity as of January this year
right okay councilor casting yeah
we um we say yeah outlines been and that
was the time to prevent this but um in
the reserve matters which we talk about
layout and we talk about numbers of
houses on the site so um I think this
could come down to
um what number of houses on the site in
reserve matters do preserve the water
quality under this paragraph 174e
so um I think it is Rel I think it's
still relevant to reserve matters
because we're talking about how many
houses on that site feed into the sewage
and that's a capacity issue so for me I
don't I don't agree that this we've
we've missed both on this one but I
quite like people to um
because you know I've just been given
legal advice that we can't and now
if
you're making a decision today on the
appearance layout and scale of the
development are you the 52 houses have
been permitted an outline if you are
satisfied and you bearing in mind the
professional advice from the lady and
gentlemen sitting in front of me that
lay out and scale
um
have some bearing and relation to that
that would be a basis for condition but
I I think my colleagues need to speak
further on that yeah um no I appreciate
that and I think if you are content that
the layout is is
one of the drivers for that that is a
relation to the reserve matters
um
and if that's you know the particular
concern of committee I think we might
just want to just check in with the
agent before we went on that but the
possibility of
um the additional condition securing the
phasing of the layout in accordance with
the foul water drainage infrastructure
does that seem to capture the particular
concern in that what you're saying is
the phasing all right I'll come to in a
minute
but what cancer might be saying and
please could you correct me you want 20
houses not 52 ounces is that what you're
saying yes
because you and I were
20 has or 50 houses we're not the expert
Engineers no don't create the better
problem but they've already got outlined
for this number of houses whether it was
20 years ago it was when we didn't have
a five-year land Sublime which was a bit
unfortunate yeah no but what I'm saying
is in reserve matters we're looking at
the number of houses on the site and
there probably is a number where we
don't see any issues with capacity and
water where it does sound like there's
already issues but um there might be a
number a um a point a Tipping Point as
it were that we are over capacity and
that for me is reserve matters and that
is something that we can discuss in this
um we can discuss it but we have no
technical knowledge as to whether we say
well they can put 10 houses there or not
no no where I'm coming from no and this
is why I'm talking with the condition
and it would be a completely led by a um
a capacity assessment on that site
so I think that's what I'm suggesting
chair if I might um that essentially
we've granted 52 we know that um that's
where we're at but what we can do
through the phasing of the layout
specifically is that as you say if 20
don't need any infrastructure right your
phases go and build 20 but what you
can't do is build the remainder until
you've got the phasing joined together
with anglian Waters infrastructure so I
think there is possibly I'll defer to
Ian if that does enough on Landscaping
I mean can I just throw into the mix if
I'm having a good old debate why not
um is that
um
if we don't
help both sides
but we're going to come unstuck and
stock it can put that in
it might again give comfort
no I think that's that's what I was
looking at you know
probably between me and I we might
prefer an informative but a hearing what
you've said in that particular relation
to the layout that Council customers set
out I think that gives us enough room to
say that but I think we might just be
helpful to hear that the agent
um has got any comments on that before
we proceed or if you wanted us to take
that off the room separately Jeff if
that's helpful
do that before you put your time because
you wanted to comment on on what others
have said yeah but can I can we just
have the officers talking to the agent
about what we're talking about well if
you want but what I want to say is
relevant but find our way okay if it's
relevant carry on I I completely agree
with our legal and planning advice that
there is already outline permission for
52 houses here I actually think that
this developer has done a reasonable job
of providing a good layout uh blah blah
all the rest of the stuff that is in
reserve matters and I and I'm a bit
concerned about putting the onus for the
water drainage onto the developer
um so personally and I may uh clearly
disagree maybe I'm in disagreement with
the rest of the committee I think all we
can do really is an informative I I even
if there is other and you talked about
phasing
I I'd like to know whether that is
phasing on on building or occupation
because I think there was a bit of a
confusion there but I uh speaking from
experience with other developers I I
think the developer would do if from
what we've heard today I think this
developer seems pretty honorable I think
the developer will do their bit but I
don't think we can hold them to account
for anglian Waters Behavior much as we
all don't want any more sewage to be
discharged into the watercourses we've
already got permission for 52 houses I
think this is a pretty reasonable scheme
I'd be happy to support it yes please do
as much as you can to persuade Andy
mortar to
um do their bit but I don't think we've
got the power to do that so I'd be happy
to
propose a to make a proposal that we
Grant planning permission
thank you for that um
do we have a second into that before we
go to the Canadian Council of Norris
star councilman
um
uh the question I have been puzzling
with is can you refuse an application by
a developer on the basis that a third
party in this instance only more I
haven't done what they should have done
and I think we've been we've explored
all of that I do have concerns about
May uh described a little while ago
which was the further 200 houses in the
area on top the existing 280 houses and
obviously there's implications for
exacerbation of the risk of the sewerage
polluted flooding but overall I don't
think in my opinion that we have plans
for refusing the supplication so I'm
happy to Second the recommendation for
thank you very much councilman you
wanted to speak and but councilor Gould
as well yeah Council Gould sorry
foreign
summary of the position I think is
absolutely right uh I think the
developer
um has done an excellent job here uh and
it sends the concerns I have are beyond
the scope of our decision here
um and and our past which are the wider
points about
um as as voice by councilor mayor I just
wanted if I made to clarify what is
perhaps my misunderstanding about uh
what
um Gemma said in relation to Anglia
water I thought he said it was for them
to
raise concerns about the cumulative
effect of development and yet at the
same time we've been understood from
earlier in the discussion that it is for
them to
resolve matters
um whatever the conditions are around
our our decisions so that's
they seem to me to be slightly
contradictory
but they know they'll have to deliver it
so that's that's one scenario equally
they could know that we've got 200
houses coming and therefore we have
pre-built the capacity that's an unusual
scenario but then other things might
happen so it is a changing position that
is a difficult one I suppose for them to
pin down up until the point that we've
got a developer coming forward and
saying here's my delivery date that's
the minute we're going to join up that's
the moment we need the capacity
delivered for and I suppose that's the
degree at which
we've got it involved has been that
phasing to say okay if angling water
today so we've got a capacity of 20.
fine everybody's quite happy haven't got
capacity for the remainder well hold on
those until the capacity comes forward
so it is just this ever-changing
scenario and that's why that would be
the position I would get to if we really
felt we absolutely had to through that
link to the layout
still perhaps as you can tell Ian and I
have not come forward and said yeah
we'll do that we'll do that that's fine
we're we're struggling a little with
that but that would be the one
change that we could potentially do that
through if members felt they really had
to but ultimately in general that would
have to be agreed with angling water as
developers come forward that has been
the mechanism to date
um and essentially what we rely on
through that process
um and I suppose the other thing I would
say is if you're buying a house you're
not going to buy it unless it's
connected now that is another capacity
issue but ultimately that angling Waters
door and that's the difficulty isn't it
that their responsibility versus what we
can and can't control
does that help anymore because it is
such a complex one sorry well I think
we've got a vote so
Council wall voice
but I thought you wanted to vote through
it you wanted you were quite determined
that we need devoted well thank you
chair and I have to say I do disagree
with um with councilor Mansell and uh
and uh and Mike um
always have a mental block with this
retiring
um
so um
it's there in the title that we're
discussing today
submission of details the direction of
52 dwellings with Associated Landscaping
drainage and ecological works so to my
my drainage includes surface water
drainage and includes foul drainage so
it is within the scope of our
discussions today
I I think
we seem to be moving towards some sort
of condition that might be applied I
would be very happy with that if we're
not going to do that I'm a little
concerned about um
voting in favor of this application for
all its other merits
um yes I I think I would
thank you I think I'd be on it I find it
very difficult to support the
application in fact I would until its
present perform I I think
Gemma has put forward
a compromise situation where we can have
a phase development
um an Anglia water
they will say they've got adequate
capacity because they've got to say
they've got adequate capacity because
they can't refuse to connect the system
so they're in a illegal not as that as
far as I understand to
agreed to it
um but I think the phase development
does put the pressure on them to
actually sort of come up with a a scheme
that would satisfy
um I think in the long run public
opinion that there are actually
providing a service
the consequences of of getting this
decision wrong are
because it is such a precedent for the
developments but the sewage if he
overflows into the root of a system it
doesn't go anywhere else as far as I
could tell from the map
uh that river system is enclosed in a
River Basin it doesn't ultimately end
out into the Open Open Sea not the
family happy with that either but
it literally the sewage stays
stays there
whatever
[Music]
um
so it it has got wider implications
um so I think gemma's proposal is good
compromise I think it does put pressure
on Anglia Waters it is it's
unfortunately puts pressure on the
developer because I think
um faux Jim is a part I think it's a
good development and they've gone 57 as
I say 57 above expectations in regarding
um sustainability
um and I'd like to support that
developer development but
we we need to sort of address the
consequences very seriously and get and
get it right
thank you for that well I too am very
unhappy that we haven't got a condition
on well not a condition an informative
on because if we listen to the ward
member he's the person on the ground and
if we listen to everybody's passion
about ecology and so on and so forth
we're going against the grain so I'm
unhappy that we haven't got even an
informative
um so I won't be voting with this and to
can I finish
and to and to vote on a straight yes or
no with the with the things as we'd had
such in-depth discussions about it I
think is very poor so um that's where I
sit I would want just an informative
um which would assist
um councilor Caston
um yeah not in support of of this I am I
don't believe that this shouldn't be
allowed I just want the um conditions
that we spoke about they're not perfect
I completely accept that they're not
perfect but I think they're the the um
the best we can do or the best we've
come to support
um councilman and Council War boys view
on this I think um
I feel a little bit for the developers
because it's putting pressure on them
but at some we do need to deal with this
the um we we can't let this result in
another development that's not
necessarily got capacity but there's
nothing we can do so um I will vote
against this one but um should I get
another vote with conditions I will vote
for
um approval with those with the
conditions that Gemma absolutely and
what worries me is if we have a straight
yes no and this gets refused then I
think it's very poor that we didn't
really consider to just put an
informative on it councilor Mansell you
wanted to speak
I did actually say that I would like an
informative I I thought I did but fair
enough
um but there's nothing to stop anybody
proposing an amendment
then I propose we do have an amendment
for an informative on the lines that
Gemma was taking please
um I'm happy to accept that yeah thank
you and then and will the secondary
accept that
and councilor Muller uh yes thank you
very much I've listened to everything
um with great interest and I totally
agree with you I can support this with
the informative without the informative
I'm afraid I couldn't support it exactly
okay thank you and anyone else wish to
speak
there's no condition it's just an
informative
I say it has to can we clarify that is
that the best way forward rather than it
has to do yeah yeah I think we're all
comfortable with that because as
councilor Mansell did point out to put a
condition on it is difficult to get it
in force whereas an informative will
assist at the next stage
mate just for the avoidance of any
possible doubt
um we the councilman Mansell is
proposing councilman Norris is seconding
the off the office essentially the
officer's recommendation with an
informative as an advised by General I
don't know if we need to check which was
phasing yeah that was it that's what I
have with the additional informative for
the delivery of anglian water
infrastructure to be alongside the
phasing of the development but develop
some rewarding
can we conclude on that
it's an informative
it's not a pleasant condition you can
get your conditions at the next sitting
you might be here
an informative is not a planning
Condition it's some
on the permission
as advisory and
inspirational
um
that would you
ready to go then in that case then we
have the availability to voting
thank you chair members other is now in
progress
councilor Mellon do you want me to take
your vote verbally yeah sorry the I.T
isn't behaving I'm going to vote against
thank you chair
seven votes for and one against
thank you very much for a very Lively
and informative debate I think that
proved to be very very interesting
um and um again to the developer if you
want to have a look at the Lucy group
limited they have
um
lamp posts with electric plugins which
in a more perhaps Urban
place might be something you might
consider using I'm going to give that to
the planning officers so I'm sure
they'll be looking at it thank you very
much for your patience I think we'll
have a quick 10 minute break now I think
we all need it after that thank you very
much everyone
foreign
well welcome back and thank you very
much
um we move on to the second application
of the day
and we have Nikita who's going to
present the case to US unit 1 8
gippingway's Stone Market off you go
thank you Chan good morning members
so this is application
dc2300996 at unit 1B gipping way in
Stone Market The Proposal is for the
installation of two shop front door sets
and Associated Paving to the frontage of
the unit
the reason this application has been
brought to committee today is because
the site is on Council own land and
mid-suffolk District Council are the
applicants
this is the site location plan with the
red highlighting the area where the
proposed door sets and Associated Paving
is to be located and the blue
highlighting the surrounding area owned
by mid-suffolk District Council
here is the site in relation to The
Stone Market Town Center which includes
the chat the train station the Saint
Mary's and St Peter's Church and the
Asda superstore
this is a closer aerial view of the site
showing the parking arrangements to the
southwest of the site
this is the constraints map showing that
the site is within the designated Stone
Market Conservation Area with grade 2
and grade 2 Star listed buildings nearby
here is the existing site plan which
shows that the unit is part of an
existing commercial unit and that the
door sets are to the frontage of unit 1B
this is the existing floor plan showing
that the adjacent business of pure gym
which is highlighted in pink and the
Papa John's highlighted in yellow to the
the West Side just for clarity the
application does not include a change of
use for unit 1B and the application is
purely to install the Dorset and the
associated Paving
these are the existing elevations which
show the Northwest elevations to the top
and the southeast to the bottom
here is the proposed elevations for the
dorsets on the principal elevation which
is the only elevation proposed for
change
oh there we go sorry
um yeah so here is the proposed
Innovations for the dorsets
um the bottom shows the layout of the
proposed door sets which include three
small windows to the top and two larger
panels and a door below this is also
there is also a space above the door
sets for signage should an adverse
consent advertisement consent be applied
for by a future occupier
this is a comparison between the
existing and the proposed elevations
showing how the proposal looks in the
context of the building as a whole
this is the proposed floor plan the this
shows that the proposed Paving
alterations which includes lifting and
relaying the existing Paving in order to
accommodate the proposed door sets and
create a gentle slope rather than steps
to ensure that they're a safe and easy
access into the unit
onto the site photos these are the
existing brickwork panels on the
principle elevation of unit 1B
and the red highlights where the door
sets are proposed to be placed
this shows the adjacent pure gym
business
and the other adjacent business of Papa
John's the application looks to
replicate the Dorset style that is
currently in place at Papa John's
this is the view from the site onto the
car park to the front of the unit
in summary all the Consulting responses
that were received have raised no
objection and we have also received no
local representations
as per the table papers we have
recommended and informative to be added
to the decision which highlights that
signage above the door sets are not part
of the application and a separate
advertisement consent would be required
to obtain this
based on the details out in the report
the recommendation is to Grant planning
permission with the two standard
conditions of the time limit and
approved plans and documents with the
informative set out in the table papers
thank
you thank you very much that was very
nicely presented and very clear I think
it's got everything we need but as ever
I will ask the committee do you have any
questions
councilman
yes thank you chair yeah agree very good
presentation uh one question
um these doors will they be suitable for
level access for wheelchairs push chairs
and mobility scooters and that sort of
thing
yes the associated Paving has a slight
slope so it will be easy for wheelchairs
to go into the site
any further questions
no
do we have any speakers
got off so easily
well from the chair I'm going to propose
we accept the recommendation
does anyone wish to speak to the motion
I think we've had enough speaking today
haven't we so in that case may we go to
the vote please
thank you chair members at Bow is now in
progress
councilman can I take your vote Berkeley
four
thank you
thank you chair that is eight votes for
so that is unanimous
thank you very much indeed
um
so do we have any site inspections
none received yet and the next meeting
of development control B will then be on
the 21st of June
thank you very much meeting closed